Speaker 1: Welcome to the show, the big news
over the last 24 hours, three guilty verdicts
in the killing of George Floyd by former police
officer Derek Shervin.
We covered it all live yesterday.
The verdict coming right around 5:00 p.m.
Eastern time, 4:00 p.m. local time, Central
Time in Minnesota, 10 hours of jury deliberations
before three out of three guilty verdicts.
I was not expecting this second degree murder,
guilty, third degree murder, guilty and second
degree manslaughter, guilty.
Let's go to the reading of the verdict by
the court.
Speaker 2: Please be seated.
Speaker 3: Members of the jury, I understand
you have a verdict.
Members of the jury I to read the verdicts
as they will appear in the permanent records
of the 4th Judicial District, state of Minnesota,
county of Hennepin District Court, Fourth
Judicial District, state of Minnesota, plaintiff
versus Derrick Michael Shervin, defendant,
verdict count one court file number twenty
seven S.R. two zero one two six four six.
We the jury in the above entitled manner as
to count one unintentional second degree murder
while committing a felony, find the defendant
guilty.
This verdict agreed to this 20th day of April.
Twenty twenty one that one forty four p.m.
signed juror foreperson.
Juror number nineteen.
Same caption, verdict, count two, we, the
jury in the above entitled manner as to count
to third degree murder, perpetrating an eminently
dangerous act, find the defendant guilty.
This verdict agreed to this 20th day of April
20 21 at one 45 p.m., signed by jury foreperson,
juror number 19, SAM, ception, verdict count
three, we the jury in the above entitled manner
as to count three, second degree manslaughter,
culpable negligence, creating an unreasonable
risk, find the defendant guilty.
The verdict agreed to this 20th day of April
20 21 at one forty five p.m..
Speaker 1: OK, and then immediately the prosecution
asking for Derek Chauvin to be handcuffed
and taken into custody pending sentencing,
which we will talk about, which will be about
eight weeks from now.
Here is Derek Chauvin, let out of court in
handcuffs
Speaker 3: as their motion behalf of the state.
Speaker 4: The city would move to have the
court to revoke the defendant's bail on, remand
him into custody pending sentencing.
Speaker 3: Bail is revoked, bond is discharged,
and the defendant is remanded to the custody
of the Hennepin County sheriff.
Anything further?
I thank you.
Speaker 1: We're adjourned.
So many different things to talk about here
immediately, of course, is the question of
sentencing and we have eight weeks until sentencing
and so we'll have more time to talk about
that.
But the most serious of the charges, second
degree murder potentially coming with up to
12 and a half years, according to the Minnesota
sentencing guidelines.
The prosecution has asked for a longer sentence,
saying there were kids present at the scene.
What Derrick Shervin did represent that particular
cruelty and that it included an abuse of Chauvin's
position of authority.
Chauvin is 45 years old and the sentencing
will take place in eight weeks.
And we will see if there is the possibility
in total of what would be theoretically close
to a life sentence for Derrick Chauvin or
not.
And although one can make the case that his
lawyer, Erik Nelson, failed here to secure
even one not guilty verdict on any of the
of the charges with the chocolate chip cookie
closing statement and all of this other stuff,
the future of Derrick Chauvin's life may well
actually be in the sentencing and there will
be time for that.
Let's talk about the implications of these
verdicts, though.
Is this the start of a change to the perception
of what police officers can get away with?
This is not a happy moment.
You know, it's not fun for people to go to
prison for killing others.
It would be better if George Floyd were alive
and there were many right wingers talking
about, oh, the left is happy now.
The left is thrilled about what's going on.
It's a celebration.
It's not a celebration that someone now goes
to prison.
It's the recognition, the recognition.
I guess I would say that given the circumstances,
there will be something approximating accountability.
It's not even really justice because George
Floyd is dead and that's irreversible.
But we're going to talk about, you know, in
a moment, there's also the realization that
this is a weird situation where the state
of Minnesota was prosecuting someone that
the state trained, in essence.
Now, I know, you know, local police departments
do their own training, but it's under the
guidance and under the framework of the state
of Minnesota.
So the state by prosecuting Shervin, is in
a sense dealing with a problem it created
as part of a policing culture that they have
a role in.
And now I understand literally in a literal
sense, the prosecutors aren't involved in
police training, but it's the idea of the
state and the state here involved on both
ends.
And there's also the statistical reality that
officers who kill people tend to avoid prosecution
or if they're prosecuted, they tend to be
acquitted.
Since 2005, out of 140 cases of police being
arrested and charged with murder or manslaughter
as a result of an on duty shooting, out of
the 140 cases, 97 have concluded, the other
43 are still pending.
So we can't say.
But of the 97 that concluded, there were seven
murder convictions.
So when you understand that there is a question
here of is this possibly the start to a change
in the culture around what happens in these
cases?
Often they get reduced to lesser offenses.
You have dismissals and then, of course, you
also have acquittals and plea deals and different
things.
So that is the result.
I did not expect three guilty verdicts.
I think I was probably leaning on kind of
a mixed verdict of not guilty and some guilty
guilty on all three, eight weeks until sentencing.
And the next question is, what, if anything,
does this say about racism?
Bigger picture.
Let's talk about
that next.